in the world that is FOX across
America with Jimmy Fallon and
the band sounds fired up is
because they are
joining us now and pretty easy
to spot on America's newsroom.
She was the only sober person
after the Bengals made to the
Super Bowl Dana Perino is here
hey Dana Perino.
>> Do you think hammer has a
great time or the greatest time
it was like to listen.
The fact that he showed up here
not in a toga on Monday.
I think is a win for everybody
I interviewed him yesterday he
was riding, yeah, I'm just a
heck of a high and.
>> It's fascinating that your
co-host has kind of become the
football mascot here at FOX and
win one for Billy yeah we're
all trying to win one for but
right now you know we're
talking today. I think the
nation is rooting for the
Bengals have to be and I asked
him.
>> Do you know a single Rams
fan. In the building. In the
building and you know, yeah and
I and I said will you replicate
the building across I mean
there's just to me it just
doesn't feel like there's a lot
of Rams fans yet.
>> Now I don't see them I mean
if they win you know this town
works wmu nobody was really
good Giants had yesterday we
went you know what at this
point, but it is fascinating.
And I'm just I'm so happy for
him, I'm so happy for
Cincinnati because those are
people by the way I love
Cincinnati about Joe burrow's
parents such a wonderful story
I asked I love that you got to
go home but that the Jo Bros
that such a talented young guy.
>> Got to go home. Yeah that's
amazing, now's a great job and
does
that happen I asked him if he's
going to one of those Joe
burrow chains because Joe
burrow walks around like a
Mister T started said, he's got
a lot of bling real yeah, so if
you start seeing hammer with
this guy didn't realize how
tall he is until he being
interviewed by one of the
sports reporters on the
sidelines after the game and
she's she must be fairly use
that as a as a very short
person myself I can say she
looks shorts me that when they
stood next to each other like
wow now he's talk oh yeah, it
was it was a monster it would
no I I watch that same images
you I think everybody's
invested in the same way that
Cincinnati is just a better
story and yes and also about
Evan macpherson. What a delight
it comes on your he knows where
his bread is buttered yeah my
my only loyalty to the Rams I
kind of look like their coach
Sean mcvay of 11 oh yeah I can
see that look like I'm in that
as of yet the behind the music
Sean mcvay where he wins the
Super Bowl. But now he takes a
wrong turn and why that movie
take home. That's when it comes
to sweet home team home team on
netflix that just came out and
I didn't see okay so as Sean
Payton isn't it right the coach
of
the Saints. They wouldn't talk
to us, but it's it's Kevin
James is Sean Payton is yeah I
think that the interviewed on
the other day I I don't even
remember that as a store a
barely remember that has a
story about how that At the
Saints. But I think is kind of
cool I did know that he goes
back to his hometown team and
coaches the Little League
football team, yes, actually
like kind of a really nice
story. Yeah, you know the DEM
talk about redemption and I'm
not supposed to talk a little
e-sports just because of my
gambling problem of lost a lot
of money a tee ball over the
years Perino it's not pretty
yeah it's going to news sports
betting here you into
I've so actually I'm doing OK
if to answer the question of
how it's going I am still have
fun. There's a thing about
gambling the action is great.
The outcome sometimes isn't
right. But if you know how to
separate motion
from the endeavor gambling is
phenomenal, you know there's
always that fringe element that
isn't and that that goes with
any by South. So I don't do any
of it,
I've invested by a public from
a public policy standpoint I
had a chance to talk to Chris
Christie once about this and
when he was governor and the
legislation was going through
to allow sports gambling in New
Jersey. He said that they
estimated a 20250 billion
dollars in tax revenue, the
first year okay, you know what
it actually was a was a big a
really that's insane. So that's
that's why you're going to
cease other states are going to
say well why why would we let
that happen in New Jersey here
as a former cab driver, my
first reaction to that
750 billion number as and
they're still charging $23 to
cross the George Washington
Bridge actually like to get and
get this. Here's another thing
that he told me
because with the technology you
can see where the.
That's a day from yes where
they're coming from like a
little ping. I think.
So many of them are happening
at like 9.20 in the morning.
Right across the bridges.
As you went over the bridge
that you could do all year and
then you would go back home to
New York location location is
spending 23 Grant 3, $3, ago
place your bet trying to win
that toll money that's what
happened during the best
football these tolls got so
pricey. Dana Perino is in
studio we're talking about the
great bill Hemmer and sports
gambling we've all been pulling
for him the other thing we're
always pulling for here at FOX
is obviously the police.
The former White House press
secretary I want to ask you
this. We were most surprised to
see Jen psaki displaying what I
would consider to be it was
almost like an indifference to
the spike in crime when she was
talking on the pod save America
podcast and I didn't think the
clarification was much better
if we reading too much into
this or did she seem a little
flippant well.
I haven't actually had a chance
to talk about and so I'm glad I
do because we have a little bit
more time uranium gas were here
fact
she says she was taken out of
context but if you
read the entire transcript of
what she said I don't think
it's all that much better.
Yeah but here's a 5 year have
you ever listen to pods pod
save America, not a time I mean
not not consensual we would
probably want to yes several
hostage, Sarah actions began
with yeah. But those are her
friends. And you know the worst
interview to do is the one with
your friends. It is true,
especially if you're the White
House press secretary because
here I did even there wasn't
even a podcast situation when I
was press secretary right but
so here she is chatting with
their bodies. Right and
you think well is this how they
talk about us behind closed
doors probably do, but
unfortunately I sometimes you
let down your guard all of us
could be on camera or on a Mike
at all times and that
I'm comfortable way to live to
be on guard all the time.
However, the White House press
secretary job has one. That is
extremely serious and it did
not reflect well on her book
forget that yeah she could have
that it says it doesn't look
good for the president and the
point they're trying to make
and the on substance, what
they'll say is the president.
Offered all this money in
American rescue plan.
4 cops in the Republicans voted
against it and then you dig a
little deeper the well even the
Washington Post has 3
pinocchios because that money
was here's up.
>> And cities and states you
can decide and they did so you
can spend it on cops but I
didn't see us spend this to
shore up the place. But that's
not even the problem I think
that more money for police.
First responders across
countries always welcome.
It's not just the money.
It's the policy.
It's the progressive
prosecutors and what they don't
seem to understand is that
the Democrats fully
100% own the progressive
prosecutors and when you had
the young widow. At the funeral
last week who specifically said
Alvin Bragg you are the problem
and I hope that my
just killed husband is speaking
through me to you.
The Democrats seem to not
realize that this is happening.
Yeah and project forward to the
end of November 2022. And all
these media. They're going to
go out and do stories about.
America is really worried about
crime how did we miss it.
>> It's a great medium Perce
nation by the way did not
really really what do you
got coming. So when I was
briefed President Bush I would
go in and say here's a question
you're likely to get today and
we'll go through them, but he
said he's.
>> A great compliment to me is
he said he was never surprised
by a question when I briefed
him for a press conference
great that when he doesn't say
is that I could nail
the tone. I was exactly the
language by which the question
is going to come.
>> Then a pretty you can see
are at the Mirage hotel and
casino this weekend. The one of
a 1000 now it's at that's
hilarious to me and I do think
to your point
that they are so wildly out of
touch with a lot of bases,
basic issues that aren't even
partisan issues crimes of a
partisan issue okay they might
have partisan stances but it
affects all Americans just the
same as inflation has almost
been like a defiance like when
it comes to areas where they're
failing the country.
They've emphasized perception
over reality I think the
average person doesn't have the
luxury of basking in the
perception that the streets not
safe if they can't afford goods
and that's where I set himself
up for like a real problem,
but what I'm fascinated by is
you know they do have like you
know consulting firm they do
have focus groups they do have
strategy firms. But are people
strategy friends is derelict in
their duty as these politicians
are.
>> I think that it has you seen
this political realignment
which is a fascinating thing to
live through right when I was
kid the Democrats had the
working class completely.
Who now are the consultants.
They are the Friends of the
people that are in power also
that and they all I remember
this particular in Washington.
Who were in the briefing room
often were dating. The people
who had been in the
Clinton administration. He
writes and vice versa and that
happened in the obama it will
be fair Bill Clinton was dating
the people in the Clinton
administration it was kind of
which raised in the Jets locker
>> He is apparently resigned
after admitting to an affair
with a or at least a relation
of any way with a colleague.
He had previously disclosed
my question to you because we
don't a lot of information at
our disposal right now so that
we can to speculate right.
Recklessly that's the whole joy
I just said that Jen psaki
shouldn't do that on pod save
it. Yeah hold on a second.
I sometimes think when you look
at the ratings difficulty
they've had at CNN
and I do believe their biggest
viewership is from you guys
playing CNN clips on the 5 and
laughing at them. 100% it is
right, it's a 100 Senate is
okay. I do think this might
have been you know part of a
larger issue, you know in that
there was a groundswell to get
him out of there anyway, and
there might have even someone
said to me off the air.
Maybe some residual effect from
the Chris Cuomo fire I think
it's 100% what it was Yeah
absolutely absolutely because
Chris Cuomo memo what what's
the last name
Cuomo from New York You know
that you know how the politics
is done haha family world of
payback sun Ra has breaking
news a Jeff zucker's made
announcement right so I I
haven't had time to go back but
I recall and I think I said on
the 5 publicly.
>> The data Chris Cuomo was let
go. He issued a
written statement and which he
alluded to some sort of thing
of you haven't seen the last of
me and if you think you're
going to do me like this
just wait and see what happens
to you why it was something
more subtle than that, but if
that was the sentiment so as
soon as I thought saw that I
had 3 thought
number one. Everyone must watch
the 00:00AM tonight haha I
cannot imagine how that's going
to be number 2. I was like
how much longer to the shows
are because I got a call Greg
gutfeld haha and number 3 Chris
Cuomo.
To take down Goliath wow
how that's heavy stuff but I I
kind of believe it because I
don't really believe I know of
course because they're not the
kind of people that just go
away and forget about it these
are not wash your hands water
under the bridge people.
>> These are throw somebody off
the bridge. I think it's
Fascinating stuff we have you
ever had a bigger tease for the
5 I don't know if you can you
think of a of a segment on
that. What's the show that's
going to happen like a media
come back and it will be
Chris Cuomo
Andrew Cuomo haha well I listen
I have a theory I've discussed
this with Kennedy. I think its
some point
you are going to see network
start to hire back people who
have been thrown out you know
you might be a Matt Lauer 5
years from now is is heinous as
it sounds maybe I could see a
world where they morally
justify anything if the mice
interesting right so no he
didn't like for example come
out loud to go to jail now.
So how do you how do you pay
your debt that's the things I
did in in in in an an era where
we don't have a sentencing
that's the biggest challenge
you know we talk about this
with Whoopi Goldberg today and
I think it expands on the point
you made earlier about the
party's kind of switching
roles.
>> The left was the free speech
party for most of my life they
were the you know sex drugs and
rock'n'roll rage against the
machine and people who got rich
singing about raging against
the machine like Neil young
now like screw you I'm with big
Pharma I'm with big government,
it's just mind blowing isn't it
really strange that God says
the question have we got to a
place where politics are so
hyper partisan and emotional.
That they're denying people
their self-awareness people
don't realize how crazy they
look to everybody I think
that's true, especially look at
the pandemic yeah.
>> And all the mask of
craziness and the nonsense.
I I was I am encouraged that
this latest poll from Monmouth
says that 70% of the country
says let's move on with the
pandemic we now have this
report from Johns Hopkins
University came out today that
said guess what lockdowns don't
work did not cause more harm.
Then they benefited in terms of
getting the case is down and
now we're finding out that the
school situations complete
disaster and that masks don't
work. So why a children still
having to wear a mask
at school that one drives me
crazy I think I would be if I
if I had children I become a
militant parent you be bad you
be the school board mom but you
want to know something they're
within their right to test a
terrorist you would be banned
by Merrick Garland, I would
love to have you in my studio
right now you would be going
through a metal detector I
would move back to Wyoming
frankly home and Wyoming sounds
great doesn't it isn't space
mean it is cold and I know,
yeah I was just in Reno do
Mitchell has weakened now just
I love the West I always love
the mining towns of the relaxed
culture, let's let's plan a
road get Dana Perino.
>>